on pourrait croire à un avion en
perdition il s'agit pourtant d'une
figure parfaitement maîtrisé bienvenue
au championnat de france de voltige
aérienne qui cette année met aux prises
près de 90 pilotes dans le ciel de saint
maur alors à quelques minutes du
décollage certains procèdent aux
dernières vérifications tandis que
d'autres répètent leur partition avant
le saut dans l'inconnu
un programme avec des figures tirés au
sort on n'a pas loin de voler l'inconnu
avant de le voler devant les juges dont
il faut vraiment qu'on mentalise le plus
possible au sol et donc on va
s'entraîner en mimant exactement tout ce
que va faire l'avion en l'air avant de
partir en balles une fois l'avion lancé
ne reste plus qu'à lever les yeux et en
prendre plein la vue
[Musique]
l'avion peut atteindre jusqu'à 400 km
heure alors pas le droit à l'erreur
les juges faites au moindre écart pour
chaque figure on a des critères d'angle
de déviation dans les rotations et
chaque échec erreur de 5 degrés est
pénalisé d'un point et vous avez à voir
clair d'ici à une telle distance
abbas est une question d'entraînement on
a l'habitude souvent jugement également
instructeur voltige donc on a l'habitude
de suivre vous allez vous revoir les
avec de bons vieux ça marche ça marche
aussi pour la fédération française
d'aéronautique qui voit chaque année ses
rangs grossir la ffa compte aujourd'hui
près de 40 3000 pilotes ce qui ne
l'empêchent pas d'être accusés de
polluer l'environnement ont fait des
efforts pour améliorer je veux dire le
voile à l'impact écologique fédération
mène aujourd'hui une expérimentation de
deux vols en avion électrique s'est pas
encore prêt pour la voltige mais on peut
estimer que dans quelques années
peut-être on aura de quoi
technologiquement répondent à cette
problématique fin du championnat le 23
septembre avec pour les meilleurs
voltigeurs une chance de se qualifier
pour les prochains championnats d'europe
et du monde